MARTIN OMANDER: Hi.
Welcome to "Root Access,"
the show on Google Developers
Live about startups.
My name is Martin Omander,
and I'm joined here
by Don Dodge, longtime
investor and startup advocate.
Welcome, Don.
DON DODGE: Thanks
for having me back.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
So lots of good
viewer questions.
We'll go into one specific
question this episode
about pricing.
Macovei Vlad-- I'm sorry if
I butchered your name-- asks,
what should be the
factors determining
the initial price of an app?
And if a correction
is needed, what
should be the
transition strategy
to a lower or a
higher price point
without upsetting current or
future potential customers?
DON DODGE: Good question.
There's actually
two questions there.
So the first one is, how do
you determine the initial price
point?
Look at the competition,
and if you're
competing against an
entrenched competitor,
then you want to
price under them.
So, say, 10% to 20% under
the entrenched competitor.
If there aren't
entrenched competitors,
then there are alternatives.
Like there might not be
a product or service that
is exactly like yours, but
there's always an alternative.
If there's a need there,
they've figured out some way
to solve the problem.
Maybe it's not as elegant as
your solution or as efficient
as your solution, but
there are ways to do it.
So you have to look
at how are users
solving the problem today?
And how much are they
paying to do that?
And if they switch to
your product or service,
how much additional productivity
or gains are they getting
so that they'll perhaps pay
more than the existing solution?
So that's two ways to look
at how to price your product.
Either against the competition
and come in a little lower,
or against the alternatives
that may be inferior
and price a little higher.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
So then you get
your initial price,
and pretty soon you'll discover
that you weren't spot on.
You will need to change it.
What are the strategies
for going up or going down?
DON DODGE: Good question.
My experience is
it's easier to go up
in price than it is
to go down in price.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh really?
I thought it would
be the opposite.
Everybody likes
something cheaper.
DON DODGE: Except the customers
who already paid for it.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh.
DON DODGE: So if you take
your product out at a price,
say $100, and customers
pay $100 and you
start getting customers.
But you're not getting enough,
and then you lower it to $75,
well, now you've alienated
all of those customers who
paid $100.
They're going to be angry.
You've disrupted the
value proposition
that you had going in.
So now where are you
versus the competition?
And so you need to
think very carefully
before lowering the price.
It's easier to come into
the market at a low price
and then raise the
price higher and higher.
The reason for that
is that typically when
you raise the price, you're
giving additional features.
So you're making
the product better,
you're making it scale better,
you're making it faster,
you're having
additional features.
There's more value
there, so customers
are willing to pay more money.
So in my experience,
it's always easier
to go up in price
than it is to go down.
MARTIN OMANDER: Hmm.
Interesting.
About that freemium, there's
a lot of talk about freemium.
Is that the way to go, to have
a free tier and a premium tier?
DON DODGE: Yeah, that's
a great way to go.
Because the idea behind
freemium is that if it's free,
you'll get a big
user base and lots
of network effects and feedback
from users that are free,
and that's OK.
And then you have a premium set.
That's where the "emium"
in "freemium" comes from,
the premium set of features that
they'll be willing to pay for.
So that's a great way to go.
And then that allows you to have
the free, or low price, option
and the higher priced
premium option.
You can also do that
with no freemium model.
You can just have a
base product that's
$100 and an advanced
product that's
$150 and a pro
product that's $300.
So there are lots of ways
to do packaging and pricing,
and you don't need to be tied
down to any particular model.
MARTIN OMANDER:
And you shouldn't
be too afraid to get it wrong,
because you can change it.
DON DODGE: Right.
Exactly.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
Macovei also brings
up a great question.
What about ads?
That would be great.
Then I don't have to
charge any of my users.
DON DODGE: Oh, so an
ad supported model?
MARTIN OMANDER: Ad
supported model, yeah.
DON DODGE: Yeah.
Ad supported model
was very, very popular
about 10 years ago,
five years ago.
Lots of web content companies,
where viewing the content
was free and it was
ad supported or--
MARTIN OMANDER: I started one of
those that crashed and burned.
DON DODGE: Well, it's
a very good model.
Google itself is ad supported.
MARTIN OMANDER: Mm hmm.
DON DODGE: So Google is
an ad supported model.
But ad supported sort of assumes
that you have a huge audience.
Lots and lots of page views,
lots and lots of users.
Because when you do the
math on how many page views
you need to make a million
dollars in revenue through ads,
it's billions of page views.
I mean, it's significant.
So you have to have a
pretty significant audience
to make ad supported
alone work well.
Remnant ads-- and typically
remnant ads or run of the house
ads that aren't that targeted,
those are the kinds that sell
for $0.10 CPMs-- CPM
means cost per 1,000--
or very low kinds of prices.
No one's going to make a
lot of money doing that.
Conversely, if you're using
Google AdWords or AdSense,
those are very
targeted ads, so you
don't need billions
of page views.
You just need a very targeted
audience and an advertiser
who's willing to pay a very
significant cost per 1,000
or a cost per click rate because
you have a targeted audience.
So those are the two ways
to look at ad supported.
It's if you have a
very targeted audience
where you can use Google
AdWords and command
pretty high cost per
click rates, that
can work very, very well.
If it's a CPM kind of run of
the house remnant inventory,
you better have billions of
page views to make that work.
MARTIN OMANDER: Billions.
That's a big number.
DON DODGE: It is.
But there are lots
of websites out there
that do have that kind of
traffic and can make that work,
and that aren't
solely ad supported.
Ad supported is one of
the revenue streams,
and it can be significant.
So you need to look at
your product, your users,
your audience to see whether
ad supported will work
as the sole revenue source
or as one component of it.
MARTIN OMANDER: So when I see
ads all over the internet,
a lot of that is just people
generating incremental revenue
on top of what they
would otherwise?
DON DODGE: Right.
Yeah, typically it's a nice way
to have an incremental revenue
source.
But it's not what their whole
business is predicated on.
So it's a nice little
revenue stream,
but probably not going
to make you rich.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, great.
Thanks Don.
DON DODGE: Thank you.
MARTIN OMANDER: Macovei, I hope
that answered your question.
Anyone else, if
you have questions,
please add them in
our YouTube comments.
We love questions,
and we'll pick them up
in future episodes.
Also if you're a cloud
developer and you
want to run your stuff on
Google's infrastructure,
there is an offer now.
If you're "Root Access"
viewers, check the information
on the screen.
You can sign up and get $2,000
worth of free use of the Google
Cloud Platform to
get you started.
And that's it for today.
See you next time.